- [Voiceover] The backwards baseball cap.
The sunglasses.
The punny name.
This is Lou Seal, mascot for
the San Francisco Giants.
Before they had Lou, the
Giants did something,
well, a little crazy.
It was 1984 and the
Giants weren't just bad,
they were awful.
To offset the team's losing streak,
they created an
anti-mascot, the Crazy Crab,
so fans would have something
other than the team to hate.
And it actually worked.
But the love/hate relationship
quickly turned into a
hate/hate relationship.
Things got out of hand.
The fans and even players started throwing
things at the Crazy Crab.
Due to safety issues, the Giants pulled
the Crazy Crab anti-mascot for good.
This is where the lovable
anti-anti-mascot comes in.
Lou Seal was born on Farallon Island.
He's a bay area native and one cool dude.
He's universally beloved
and a crowd favorite.
A far cry from the anti-mascot
formerly known as Crazy Crab.